jacqueline vous avez posté une vidéo
contre la hausse du prix du carbone
rivier devient énorme agit plus de 6
millions de vues on va regarder puis un
extrait de la vidéo et jacqueline vous
allez vous exprimer après et on a un
autre garçon qui a posté une vidéo lui
ça n'a rien à voir
lui c'est un coup de gueule contre ceux
qui sont mécontents de la hausse du prix
du carburant il ne vous aime pas et lui
il est dans le public
anthony du c'est faux anthony vous allez
voir sa vidéo si anthony pour l'instant
jacqueline regardez j'ai deux petits
mots à dire à monsieur vaincrons et son
gouvernement
la hausse du prix du carburant un euro
cinquante mais tout le monde s'en fout
personne ne dit rien pourquoi on dit
rien parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
d'être dans la rue parce qu'il faut
qu'on paye les impôts que vous ne savez
gentiment envoyé l'arc pour la fin de
l'année qu'est ce que vous faites du
pognon et je suis certaine qu'il ya au
moins 80 % des gens qui m'écoutent qui
sont d'accord avec moi
alors chacun y joue un petit peu de
carburant jacqueline donc vous êtes
énervé vous êtes colère si vous avez
marine au bec et marie vraiment merci
telle venue ce soir d'être extrêmement
courageuse parce que on sait s'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas voulu
venir au soul dit ah ouais mais marie
lci bah oui je vais être
et marié merci parce que franchement
c'est très courageux et voilà je joue
les saluer sa jacqueline mots
donc vous avez fait le buzz avec cette
vidéo déjà pourquoi vous avez publié
cette vidéo vous vous prenez beaucoup la
voiture vous faites quoi noël fait vingt
cinq mille kilomètres par an roxio vet
tour de france en voiture
non mais voilà pour mon travail eh ben
je suis obligée d'avoir fait quoi dans
la vie suit nos thérapeutes et artistes
hypnothérapeute donc c'est je connais on
peut rappeler ce que c'est a rappelé que
ça quand même mais bon voilà c'est de la
thérapie par l'hypnose très bien voilà
et moi je travaille à domicilie plus
hypes narry et thérapie voilà c'est ça
alors oui donc vous travaillez à
domicile donc vous allez chez des
personnes forcément votre voiture et
votre outil de travail est donc là ça
c'est certain
est ce que cette hausse du carburant va
changer votre rythme de vie franchement
là actuellement je suis en train de me
demander si je dois continuer à
travailler parce que vous avez fait des
comptes à bas mais de toute façon
aujourd'hui bientôt là ça ne sert plus à
rien de travailler à cause de chutes du
carburant bien sûr ouais non pièce à
falun su c'est un tout ou en partie
on va partir avec tout ce qu'on est tous
qu'on nous ponctionne aujourd'hui eh
bien on rend plus que ce qu'on gagne
donc quelle est l'utilité d'aller
travailler parce que là moi je parle pas
des personnes qui sont ici je parle pour
les gens les plus de six millions de
personnes qui m'ont regardé ce sont des
gens qui gagnent moins de 900 euros par
mineur c'est vrai c'est vrai alors je
suis heureuse madame la députée de vous
avoir en face de moi
déjà c'est très courageux c'est sûr mais
moi je vais vous dire une chose qu'avez
vous à dire aux personnes qui gagnent
moins de 900 euros par mois qui ne
peuvent avoir aucun crédit pour acheter
une voiture et à qui vous allez enlever
les véhicules à partir du mois de
janvier prochain
parce que vous avez à lourdes et le
contrôle technique vous allez mettre à
la maison des gens qui vont rester chez
eux pour même pas aller faire leurs
courses
alors avant de pondre des décisions il
faut réfléchir aux conséquences
marie non mais je pense qu il
c'est assez concret ce qui pose comme
question et c'est vrai que ça ça touche
énormément de gens taxes plus tard hélas
assez simple acte quand on met tout à
côté un moment aussi est-ce que ça sert
à quelque chose de sortir de chez nous
alors qu'on était censé valoriser le
travail alors marie effectivement il
faut se poser la question pour les gens
qui vont avoir des difficultés à changer
leur voiture il faut pas on n'est pas
avec des oeillères et on continue la
discussion c'est pour ça que le
président aujourd'hui fait plusieurs
annonces en la matière est dit qu il y a
des pistes qui sont en cours de
réflexion qui sont par brit air on a
effectivement regarder la proposition
qui était portée par xavier bertrand on
veut travailler sur la prime à la
conversion on demande aux constructeurs
automobiles de continuer à nous aider
dans cette dynamique parce qu'on voit
que ça marche très bien et que ça incite
les gens à aller vers des véhicules
neufs plus moderne parfois je électrique
pour certains excusez-moi de vous couper
mari mais juste une petite question
juste quand elle a dit avant de prendre
des décisions il faut peut-être voir
toutes les conséquences là vous dites
que vous êtes en train d'étudier des
solutions pourquoi avant de faire cette
hausse du prix des carburants ne pas
étudier peut-être les solutions avant et
de dire voilà on va augmenter le
carburant mais derrière on va faire ça
ça et ça qu'il ya des solutions qui vont
faire que vous allez voir ce fallait
faire l' inverse il fallait d'abord
mettre mais ça ça et ça et après donc
ses skis d'homme est bon ou non mais
aujourd'hui encore une fois mais juste
encore une fois on attend donc la prime
à la chanson dans la rue entre ont juste
à les séparer
vous dites il faut faire les choses
avant j'aurais quand même qu'on
rétablisse une vérité la prime à la
conversion vous alors vous pouvez
toujours me dire c'est pas assez ça va
pas assez loin et c'est en mai la prime
que la conversion elle a été lancée en
2007 elle a été renforcée en 2018 elle
va être à nouveau renforcée en 2019 on
demande aux constructeurs de voiliers je
veux dire c'est quelque chose
qui est fait en amont de cette
augmentation par ailleurs je voudrais
quand même rappeler quelque chose c'est
que cet alignement de la fiscalité du
diesel sur celle de l'essence on l'avait
annoncé pendant la campagne on avait
annoncé qu'on le ferait donc je veux
dire c'est pas une mesure qui sort du
chapeau c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
décide comme ça arbitre m
c'est une mesure qu'on croit absolument
nécessaire pour lutter contre la
pollution et qui s'insère dans la global
dont lens dans l'ensemble des politiques
qui visent à lutter contre la pollution
et elle prend plein de formes elle prend
la pollution de l'air mais les places et
les produits phytosanitaires et autres
réalisé drogba est ouvert voilà on a mis
ça dans un petit un petit paquet ouvert
mais la réalité de la vie c'est pas ça
madame qu'est ce que vous allez trouvez
moi une banque qui prête à quelqu'un qui
gagnent moins de 900 euros par mois
je vous mets au défi de la trouver pour
que cette banque prête à des gens qui
vont se retrouver sans bagnole au mois
de janvier
y'a aucune personne alors en plus vous
avez installé le cdi de chantier les
gens sont débauchés il ya trois mois
laissait plus trois mois à l'essai ils
sont débauchés au bout de six mois non
mais vous croyez crédit comme ça à
damour essayons de ne pas tout mélanger
je veux dire il ya la fiscalité
écologique et bakula fisc et non non non
c'est faux et à la musicalité était
logique
ai-je entendu parfaitement ce que vous
dites mais moi je sais effectivement
quand quand j'étais dans les vosges où
vous savez le un peu le couple type
quand vous vivez en milieu rural c'est
le mari qui était agriculteur et la
femme qui est infirmière libérale et qui
fait un certain nombre de kilomètres
donc le sait le sujet n'est pas de se
dire on se met des oeillères et on voit
pas ces situations là je suis bien
consciente et il ya un effectivement un
enjeu sur les personnes qui ont yagg des
très petits revenus qui vont des
difficultés pour moi le sujet c'est pas
ça effectivement on est bien sûr on veut
augmenter justement les aides que
peuvent avoir les cas soit pour prendre
en charge les trajets comme comme on
parlait d'un terminal libéral qui va
faire un certain nombre de kilomètres où
les outils comme la prime avec 20 euros
par mois qu'est ce que vous allez faire
moi j'ai une petite mois des témoignages
j'en ai reçu des milliers des milliers
de témoignages
la france souffre là il ya des français
qui crèvent de faim vous rendez vous
alors vous allez c'est moi les sons
je vais vous dire moi la suite j'ai reçu
un témoignage d'une petite aide
soignante qui met 150 euros de gasoil
dans sa bagnole pour gagner 120 euros
vous la contrée au nombre des chômeurs
parce qu'elle arrête pas d'amour au
vigan améliorer le chômage d'amour ou
quelqu'un avec une 9 qui consomment
moins c'est aussi des économique mais
comment c'est à l'uci méric madame la
députée je crois que ça va plus loin que
le mépris des conséquences des décisions
qu'on prend c'est que les français ne
comprennent pas pour qu'une mesure soit
accepté il faut la comprendre
au moment où il ya l'affichage de on va
faire un effort pour le pouvoir d'achat
on baisse les charges on va baisser la
taxe d'habitation on a l'impression que
ce qui est accordé d'une main et repris
de l'autre il ya un parfum d'entourloupe
qui entoure cette hausse des taxes et
vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez
c'est inscrit dans le cerveau des
français et il pense et c'est donc
toujours c'est que c'est pas justifié
penser la taxe d'habitation inouïe mais
c'est pas ça et le pouvoir d'achat c'est
pas plus la moelle oui mais enfin ces
loisirs ou alors faut pas le dire